el nuevo polémico fichaje del athletic club
como bien sabemos
la política de traspasos
del conjunto bilbaíno es bastante estricta
y solo queda reducida a jugadores nacidos
o formados en euskal herrialas
provincias del país vasco
o formados en la comunidad foral de navarra
o el país vasco francés
pues bien llega el miguel rojiblanco kika labari
procedente del portugalete con 20 años pero de origen
de guinea pisaus hoy lleva 5 años en el país vasco
se ha formado en el barakaldo
en santuxu o henderio
donde ha sido formado como delantero
por eso
para muchos aficionados del conjunto punto bilbaíno
parece extraño
y deja entrever
sobre esta nueva política que se está realizando
porque no consideran suficiente
ese periodo de formación
para decir que ha sido formado en
euskal herría
qué te parece
para mí bastante curioso
aunque creo que debe darse este aperturismo
en el club rojo y blanco